I'm also worried that I'll have diarrhea
oh you lactose-intolerant oh [ __ ] I am I
[Music]
love hot cheetos they're like my
favorite snack I'm excited to taste like
the crunchy and spiciness against like
the milk growing up as a kid they were
like a go to I feel whatever about hot
cheetos we definitely love milkshakes I
probably need hot cheetos every day
they're the perfect complement to any
sandwich bring them on buddy let's go
[Music]
oh this is interesting it looks like
it's going to be delicious it's got this
it's like a strawberry milkshake
Cheers hmm mmm that is Bob huh Oh like
the spicy kicked in that's so good
I'm so confused one of the worst things
I've ever like felt in my mouth if you
think about it too much you're
definitely gonna you're gonna throw up
do you have hot cheetos here right now
it's actually really good
my mind keeps trying to say strawberry
milkshake it tastes so sweet but then
like it gives you that kick of like I'm
Hot Cheetos but I'm also very sweet too
honey we are eating two differing types
of milkshake this is more Oh someone
kind of chewed a bunch of hot cheetos
and then just spit them in this it's
actually good and if you love spicy food
like people that eat like tubs of spicy
ramen you would totally like this it
lived up to my expectations and I want
this all day all night no just no I'm a
little let down I really thought it was
gonna be great I thought I'd like wanna
throw up after like a first half but I
could drink more of this she almost
finished her I have no standards so this
is now the fifth most disgusting blended
thing you have been consumed